we will now go through a derivation of
the law of total variance this
particular derivation is not insightful
it will not really give you any
intuition as to why the law of total
variance is correct on the other hand it
involves some interesting manipulations
that will be useful to be able to follow
and understand the kinds of objects that
are being moved around and why each step
is valid our derivation relies on the
standard formula that we have on how to
calculate variances and our first step
is to apply this formula to the
conditional variance now the conditional
variance is like an ordinary variance
except that it is calculated in a
conditional universe so we apply this
formula except that the expectation of x
squared is the expectation calculated in
the conditional universe and similarly
for the next term is the square of the
expected value of x but it's the
expected value of x as calculated in a
conditional universe so this is an
equality between numbers what does it
translate to this has been defined as a
random variable that takes this value
when Capital y is equal to little Y what
is the random variable that takes this
value when Capital y is little Y well
this random variable here is a random
variable that takes this value when
Capital y is equal to little Y and this
random variable here is a random
variable that takes this numerical value
when Capital y is equal to little Y so
to summarize this is the random variable
that takes this numerical value when
Capital y is equal to little Y and this
is a random variable that takes this
value when Capital y is equal to little
Y
this expression the left-hand side is
equal to the right-hand side for all
wise and therefore this random variable
and that random variable always take the
same numerical values no matter what Y
happens to be so these are identical
random variables and so we have this
equality between random variables the
next step as were working towards
calculating this first term here in the
law of total variance is to take the
expectation of this expression what is
it we take the expectation of the first
term it's the expectation of a
conditional expectation and according to
the law of iterated expectations it is
the same as the unconditional
expectation and then we have the
expected value of the next term
next we want to make some progress
towards calculating this second quantity
in the law of total variance and the way
to calculate it is to just apply this
general property of variances to the
special case where X gets replaced by
the expected value of x given Y so the
first term will be the expected value of
our random variable squared our random
variable is the expected value of x
given Y and the second term involves the
expected value of the random variable
whose variance were considering so it's
the expected value of this random
variable so it's the expected value of
the conditional expectation and
everything gets squared what is this
term by the law of iterated expectations
the expected value of a conditional
expectation is the same as the
unconditional expectation so this last
term here is of this form what we will
do next is to take this expression here
and that expression here and add them
together when we add them we notice that
this term and that term are the same so
they cancel out and were left with the
expected value of x squared minus the
square of the expected value but we know
that this is the same as the variance of
X so we have proved that the sum of
these two terms which are the two terms
up here give us the variance of X